Instead of asking a friend for a hand
what if you had an extra arm?
Researchers have created a robotic limb called Aucto
that can be attached to the shoulder.
It’s lighter and simpler than previous extra limbs.
The gripper is a balloon
filled with foam pellets and coffee grounds.
It conforms to objects
and holds them tight when air is sucked out.
The body brace is soft and stiff in different regions
for both comfort
and so the user can sense the arm’s load.
A prototype arm braces objects above the head
holds tools
and frees both hands of kneeling workers.
The wearer moves the arm to a desired position
and motors in the joints hold it there.
it even maintains the gripper’s absolute position
as the worker moves
Attach three more and you can be Doctor Aucto.